Her low freak bitches,
I,
but,
but to go back to the brain warm idea,
so I coined the term not to be cute,
but to actually named this collective condition.
I called it ostrich parasitics syndrome.
Yeah.
We've talked about this before we talk about it.
I know that that's a myth,
but yeah,
yeah,
that,
it's because it's become just a metaphor for yeah,
absolutely.
The Myth being folks that ostriches don't really stick their head and they these
exactly.
Uh,
and,
and it's,
it's really taken on a life of its own at this point.
I'm actually thinking of studying this scientifically,
not just as something that I talk about on my public engagement.
What is it that causes some people to be more likely to be parasitized by the
types of mindsets that would cause you to suffer from ostrich parasitic
syndrome.
So a classic example would be,
which I guess we'll,
we'll get into
how much evidence do you need to see around the world that there might be some
religious ideology that is somewhat problematic and antithetical to secular,
liberal,
modern values?
How much information or what is the type of information that you would need to
see before you're able to arrive to such a conclusion.
And so one of the things I'm thinking of doing is to formally quantify a score
of ops.
How much somebody suffers from,
won't be as,
as a type of mindset.
And what are some predictors that could help us understand who is more or less
likely to be effect the afflicted by this mindset?
Well,
there's certain people that just never want to hurt anyone's feelings,
right?
Except when they think that it is within their rights to attack that person
because that person is somehow or another victimizing someone else.
Right.
And then there'll be far more egregious than the original offense.
Did you know about the guy that in Canada that's getting sued?
Well,
he,
the human rights council,
um,
find him $12,000 because you walked into his apartment that he owned with shoes
on us because there was a Muslim family living there.
Um,
their lease was up and he was looking to rent the apartment.
They stopped responding to his texts.
And so he opened up the apartment to show this,
uh,
this apartment that he owns and because he walked into a building that he owns
with his shoes on,
he has to pay them $12,000 for failing to accommodate their religious practices
while showing their apartment to perspective tenants.
That's crazy.
Welcome to Canada.
We just had a thing called the motion and one oh three.
Are you familiar with this?
Look at this.
Look at this statement though.
I'm sorry to interrupt you.
But the human rights count tribunal of Ontario also found that he harassed them
and created a poisoned housing environment.
It's right,
there you go.
Cause he refused to remove issues.
Some sensibilities are more equal than others,
but that is just what,
why is it that people are so,
especially in,
particularly with Muslims like that,
you'll notice that there's a lot of people that are,
they will accuse everyone of Islamophobia yet they'll shit on Christians.
Yeah.
It's really common.
Like they don't,
it's not that they believe in religious freedom,
it's that they have like a pet cause and the pet causes almost like being a
contrarian to a lot of like far right people who are really terrified of
Muslims.
Like they're trying to like figure out how to,
how to balance that out with their own ridiculous left wing version of it.
Well,
I think there are two elements to it.
One is that they're just afraid to criticize Islam just because they are greater
repercussions to do so than to criticize seventh day.
I haven't this,
so just from a very basic sort of survival instinct,
but I think secondly,
which is kind of part of the ostrich parasitics hundred will not,
speaking of,
there are all sort of erroneous ideas that people have been infected with.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the Muslim religion is a religion for the downtrodden.
The Brown people,
uh,
the exotic other and so to,
to criticize them when they are a hapless exotic minority is simply racist and
sexist.
And people believe that even though most of the countries that these people are
coming from when they come to the west,
not only are they the majority,
they're almost the exclusive majority.
Right?
So,
so they are out of I think 56 countries that constitute the OIC,
the Organization of Islamic cooperation.
Something like 29 or 30 countries.
They're exclusively Islamic.
They are no longer any religious minorities.
It's in the order of 99.9 something.
So to argue that people who come from these countries are,
you know,
religious minorities,
why me?
They religious minorities when they come to the west,
but they're all coming from countries where not nevermind that they're the
majority.
They've never interacted with someone who did not share their faith.
I don't think people understand that if that happens here,
like you can't turn back from that without violence.
Right?
Like if,
if,
I mean I'm not saying that it would happen in the United States,
but the fact that it can happen anywhere means it can happen everywhere.
I mean it really can.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a big reach on my part to say that because there's no evidence whatsoever
that it's going to happen here.
But if you really look at some of the countries that are suffering under this,
these really oppressive religious ideologies where women aren't allowed to
drive,
where they have to wear a covering all over their body,
that signifies that they're a part of this religious sect.
Like if that,
if someone tried to do that today,
like if you had some blonde haired blue eyed guy that made all women wear a
certain outfit and they weren't allowed to drive and they weren't allowed to
have the same rights,
how many people would be standing up for them?
That's incredible.
Especially if it was a new thing.
There's something about old things like old ideologies and legitimacy.
So strange.
What is that?
Uh,
while it's exactly what you said,
uh,
you take an idea that someone holds,
if he doesn't cloak,
cloak it under the robe of religion.
You commit them to a psychiatric institution.
If he says,
no,
but this belief as part of my religion,
suddenly you get a free pass.
It's grotesque.
But to speak to your point about well that you are stretching about it happening
in the United States.
You're not stretching it at all.
As a matter of fact,
I've argued,
uh,
for example,
when the,
when Trump won that if you look at a long term view of the issue of Islamic
immigration,
if,
if what you focus on is,
uh,
do we have the proper vetting processes to stop terrorists,
isis,
terrorists from coming in?
That's a very short term view of the problem.
But if you recognize that societies will take often,
very,
very long time before they become Islamized.
It's not as though every single country that today is Islamic became
instantaneously overnight Islamic.
And some cases it wasn't very,
very quick invasion and other cases it took 500 years before the demographic
reality shifted.
And so yes,
if you look at it from the perspective of 10 20,
50 a hundred years,
the u s stands no threat but take a longterm view.
I love this quote from the,
I think it was the Taliban who said that the,
the United States have all the clocks and watches we have all the time in the
world.
In other words,
in Sharla,
eventually God willing,
we will conquer you.
So this is the right way to look at this issue.
Do you wish to have a society become more Islamized or less?
Let me draw another analogy.
Uh,
at the end of every day,
you can weigh yourself and one of three things is going to happen.
You've either lost weight that they,
your weight did not change a single ounce or you've put on weight.
So let's analogize this with Islam.
When Islam comes into a place,
either the society gets better,
nothing changes,
or it gets worse.
Do we have enough data at this point,
after 1400 years to suggest that we can try to bet what will happen to the
society?
The answer regrettably is yes.
Again,
I hate to have to preface,
of course,
most Muslims are lovely and peaceful and wish to simply raise their children.
But Islam as an ideology when it comes into a new society,
is it a good thing?
If yes,
let's alternate Islamic.
If no,
then maybe we should have an honest conversation about this and honest
conversation is what's really important because these things get so emotionally
charged like the infamous Ben Affleck,
Sam Harris Debacle on Bill Maher show,
but that to me is a perfect example because Sam speaks in such a measured tone
and he's so educated about it.
He's not making these big gigantic leaps,
but people love to jump on him and call racism.
He sent me some video that I just watched the other day.
We were a bunch of people are just taking complete out of context statements,
attributing into him as being like,
this is what he believes on things.
When if you listen to the full extent of the conversation,
he's literally saying like that.
I'm going to say something here that could be taken out of context,
but what I'm saying is like,
imagine if someone was saying this right.
How do you respond to that?
And they use that as a statement.
I mean there's,
there's so much of that going on.
There's so much.
It's so dishonest.
Well,
this,
there's this weird not me thing that they're doing.
It's they,
they're,
I'm not the racist,
right.
He's the racist.
Right.
And they get very,
you are racist.
Like the Ben Affleck thing.
Like he was like,
that is so gross that it's so racist.
Like instead of just discussing this conversation,
I'm discussing this,
especially on the bill Maher show,
because that shows all those shows is not the criticized that show,
but all those shows,
we have a panel of six people.
What you see is a bunch of people waiting to say something and they'd have to
jump in and it's almost like they have to be salacious or they have to be
outrageous just to get heard.
You know,
like everyone,
it's,
it's those kinds of shows promote this sort of disingenuous communication
because you have to,
you can't be polite like you and I can be polite.
It's just you and I,
we can talk and we can have these long form conversations,
but on that show,
do you don't have the time to unpack what's wrong with all ideologies,
all things that tell you how to think.
Forget about whether or not you think it came from Jesus or the Prophet Mohammed
or Joseph Smith.
Any times there's a doctrine that tells you how to think because of some
mystical presence,
some God or Deity or prophet who has gotten the wisdom of the universe and you
meant it must not question it,
and women have to wear veils and dress up like beekeepers and I mean all that
stuff is very,
very problematic because people are prone for whatever reason.
I mean some,
I guess it's some something that goes back to tribalism and Alpha male
chimpanzee behavior we're prone to follow through.
I'm prone to follow leaders.
I mean it makes it easier and that's one of the things you're seeing here while
it looks amazing,
is that it's one thing to attack Sam because in the game of identity politics,
he scores really poorly.
Right?
He's a southern California and white male who doesn't speak any of the languages
that matter,
Arabic or so on.
And his parents had money,
that's his parents had money.
So I've loved that.
So your parents had money,
you sinner.
Exactly.
I only recently found out maybe a year,
a year and a half ago when I met him last that his mother is the creator of
golden girls is,
you know though.
No,
I didn't even know that.
Happy.
And I actually,
I,
I just looked at one of the golden girls that was rerunning and you'll see,
I think it's Susan Harris or something.
But anyways,
uh,
someone like me who comes from the Middle East who escaped that reality,
someone like Ayaan Hirsi Ali and I had many people on my show.
I don't know how much you followed,
but a lot of people who've all escaped from this world,
either they still considered themselves Muslim,
but you know,
not,
you know,
Muslim light or ex Muslims.
In many cases they will be attacked.
So imagine,
you know,
so there some woman who went to Wellesley college who doesn't know anything
about Islam,
short of whatever she learned in her bullshit progressive course,
she would lecture to us what true Islam is.
Not The people who lived under it.
Not The people who ran away from it.
She knows better because,
so it's,
it's,
it's really,
it's grotesque.
It's infuriating.
It's stunning.
And it's also confusing because like,
when,
when you them do it,
like,
uh,
I mean anytime someone goes so far overboard that objective reasoning is out the
window and you're,
you know,
you're so committed to whatever position that you're in that you can't look at
both sides of it.
I mean,
I could see why a lot of religious traditions will be comforting to people,
remind them of where they came from,
give them pride of their homeland.
We give them a personal good feeling.
They're connected to some sort of an ancient tradition.
Right.
As long as it's not a pressing other human beings and there's gotta be some,
I mean I actually cultural patterns of behavior that people do,
like celebrations like October fest or something like that.
Those things,
you know,
promote some sort of a pride like I guess a pride in Germany and their beer
making and all that stuff without oppressing people,
you know?
But by the way,
this is a good segue to what you're talking about is something that is upsetting
me these days increasingly so.
So some people are now trying to draw a distinction between Islam and Islamism.
The reason why I mentioned this is because Islam has two elements.
There's a spiritual part,
right?
Which is,
you know,
kind of like your October fest prayed this way,
believe in a god and a mono fiesta,
God and so on.
But then within Islam is a much larger component of politics,
political Islam.
So when you say something like,
well,
you know,
we should be attacking Islamism as if it's something that is outside of Islam,
that's simply false Islam.
Islam is Islam,
right?
Ird the one,
the prime minister of Turkey.
And I can quote many other,
uh,
Islamic experts said,
Islam is Islam.
The term moderate Islam Islamism and all these other qualifiers are nonsensical.
Now,
the reason why that upsets me is because [inaudible] grants people a false sense
of security and hope,
you know,
Islam is wonderful,
but we need to attack this separate thing called Islamism.
Well,
from day one,
1400 years ago,
Islam was Islam,
Islam.
Now that doesn't mean that there isn't a spiritual element.
That doesn't mean that most Muslims just want to practice the spiritual part,
but there is no set of doctrines and a separate book called radicalized Islam,
Islam.
It all comes from the same texts.
It comes from the Quran,
it comes from the head east,
and it comes from the Sierra,
the biography of Muhammad.
So,
so this kind of false narrative that people are promulgating so that they seem
as though they're not frontally attacking a religion while laudable.
While Nice,
I get that reflex,
it's false.
And so again,
to go back to our point of talking,
honestly,
we need to talk honestly,
there is only Islam.
Some people choose to practice it fully.
Some people choose to ignore the ugly part,
but there is no such thing as Islamism.
Islam,
Islam is part of Islam.
Now you're a person that goes out of your way to say,
no,
we're not talking about the kind
sweet Islamic people that just want to raise their children now.
So how do you sort of manage those two ideas that they're the same?
Like when the term radical Islam gets thrown around,
right?
So radical Islam simply means I really take my Islam seriously,
It's,
it's,
let's draw us a silly analogy.
If I don't eat pork,
uh,
my radical Jew,
or am I a Jew right now,
I happen to be Jewish.
I simply ignore the kosher edict that says don't eat pork.
That does.
Why do you do that though?
Because in my case,
I simply identify as Jewish in the sense that at Judaism as a multi attribute
identity,
it includes a shared history,
shared lineage,
sh,
sh kind of a race.
It's what some could argue it's array.
So it's considered in a lot of people's ideas.
So I could still in the same way that you might identify as coming from Boston
and there's a shared history from all people who grew up around the time that
you grew up in Boston and there was a sense of affiliation and tribalism,
would that reality being Jewish as far as I'm concerned and for most Jews is
exactly that.
We don't necessarily take the religious elements very seriously.
Now that doesn't mean that we are practicing a light Judaism or non radical
Judaism.
We're simply ignoring those parts of Judaism that we choose to ignore.
So there is no such thing as radical Islam.
There are no books called radical Islam.
There is a set of doctrines called Islam and then I could do what's called
cafeteria Islam,
which is I pick and choose the parts that I wished to adhere to.
So again,
the discourse is a false narrative.
I understand the reason for it because people find that rather Gauche to attack
frontally religion at least to attack Islam.
So they have to,
I call this the the the ism magic eucharistic rite.
You add as him to something,
it makes it bad.
Islam is good,
Islam,
Islam is bad for you.
Um,
I would like to defend you if there's a lot of people that are listening right
now or offer up some,
not,
not even defend you,
but offer up some information.
Like as you grew up in a place where being Jewish was lethal.
I mean you,
your life was threatened certainly when the civil war broke out.
Prior to that you could live in Lebanon as a Jew.
People knew that we were Jewish,
but know your place Jew.
That by the way,
is something that I explained when discussing,
and I'm not sure if we've discussed this on the show,
but it might be worth repeating if we discussed your past and Lebanon,
how you,
yeah.
Okay,
so do you know what a dummy is?
Have you heard that term?
Yeah.
Right.
You,
you explained it,
but please do again,
just Soso at them.
Me As a third class citizen comes out of Koranic edicts that basically said that
when Islam comes into a society,
you basically have three choices.
If you're not a Muslim,
you could either convert,
you could either get killed or you are people of the book,
meaning Christians and Jews,
meaning people are the book that you're also monotheistic.
You're also from an Abrahamic faith,
then you could live as it [inaudible] and then me as a protected class protected
and quotes we tolerate you.
And in order to tolerate,
you were going to remind you repeatedly of your subservient position.
Now at different points across the last 1400 years,
that mechanism was either instituted very forcefully or more lightly.
So in the context of Lebanon,
which is,
which was a very progressive and modern country in the Middle Eastern context,
there wasn't somebody knocking on our door and levying the Zizia pay us or else
we're going to rape your daughters.
But you didn't wear a big star of David because that might be construed as
inflammatory.
Just like the,
the example that you started off the show,
you're hurting our sensibilities by pushing your Judaism on us,
right?
So your,
your status,
the not always have been,
uh,
threatened in that my head is going to come off at any minute.
Right?
My parents grew up and lived there.
They didn't die.
But once the civil war broke out,
then it became lethally dangerous to be Jewish.
I think we were going to be executed.
We left.
So you never know when we're going to go from tolerating you to off with the
heads.
And that's been the history for the past 1400 years.
And so again,
when people think,
but Islam is not that bad.
Look and under Lucilia,
uh,
Jews and Christians and Muslims used to walk around hand in hand and in Spain
around the 15th,
16th century.
Bologna,
yes.
People were not being beheaded every day,
but you knew your place.
That's not equality.
And it's kind of interesting when you talk about this idea about how people are
reluctant to criticize Islam because they're worried about the repercussions of
this.
It kind of speaks to how rare it is that people do violate those principles in
those countries.
Because if you do have a culture that's 99% Islamic,
especially if they go by the book,
like every step of the way,
like there's not going to be a lot of people that are stepping on the line for
fear of the horrific repercussions.
Now psychologically in this country,
you're seeing that for some strange reason,
a emerging from the left and emerging from a lot of like really progressive
colleges and universities where they want to be almost the first ones to step up
and say,
don't criticize this one particular religion,
which is very odd because it's the most regressive.
It's unbelievable.
It's,
it's very,
it's a really strange position to be a progressive who's reinforcing the
ideologies of a regressive culture that's very ancient.
But what's incredible is that they'll come up with ways to defend this
cognitive.
Hence that's part of the ostrich parasitic syndrome that I was mentioning.
What are,
what are some ways that they defend?
So example,
uh,
and to just give you a few manifestations of ostrich logic.
Uh,
my friend Mohammed is a very nice guy and he drinks and he fornicated and he's
very liberal.
So the idea then becomes that as long as I can identify a single exemplar of a
Islamic person who does not otherwise,
uh,
adhere to what Islam dictates,
then it's not true that Islam is bad.
Now this is,
this is a manifestation of a more general cognitive bias,
which goes like this.
If I walk into class and I say,
look,
uh,
you,
homo sapiens are sexually dimorphic,
they are an eight sex differences between the two sexes.
Men are bigger than women.
Someone will put up their hand and say,
but my aunt Linda is taller than my uncle Joe.
Oh Gee,
Darwin is dead,
right?
So they,
they identify a singular exemplar that is supposed to falsify a statement that
is only true at the population level.
So here's,
so that's one example of why Mohammad is nice.
Therefore,
Islam is nice.
Here's a second example.
Uh,
they point to a particular historical context where Jews lived in Islamic
countries and weren't killed Hae.
But God said you lived in Lebanon and you still have your head.
There were a torque that I usually give as well until they were going to cut off
my head.
But secondly,
Jeffrey Dahmer,
if you take,
I think he was guilty of 17 uh,
uh,
murders.
If you take the number of days that he lived as an adult until he was caught as
a percentage of the days that he killed somebody,
99 point whatever percent of the days.
Jeffrey Dahmer is a lovely guy.
So it's unfair for you to say that Jeffrey Dahmer is a mean guy given that 99%
of the time he's nice.
So what you have to basically do is take each of these ostrich logic arguments
and analogize how the Arctic they are.
But it's very exhausting because the bent,
as you said,
of all these progressive's is to do whatever they can to protect the ideology.
And so it becomes exhausting to consistently have to try to fight through all
the clutter.
And it's not a thought that it's,
it's not something that is structured with objective reasoning.
It's something that's structured with their own particular ideology that does
not want to criticize this one segment of the human population that they think
is being persecuted.
Right?
And meanwhile,
if you think about throughout currently in the world,
which ideology persecutes the most number of other people.
So if,
if you talk about bloody borders,
right?
Islam has fought with Buddhists,
Islam fights with animus Islam,
fights with Jews,
Islam fights with Christians,
Islam fights with Tibetan monks,
right?
So in other words,
Islam doesn't necessarily make for very good neighbors.
Why?
Because again,
not withstanding the fact that most Muslims are lovely and just want to raise
their kids Islam as a supremacist ideology,
it basically says that the world is meant to all be United under the flag of a
law.
Now,
some people take that seriously,
others don't.
But the doctrines of Islam are very clear.
We should all submit to Islam.
So even if 95% of Muslims don't adhere to that t tenant,
if only 5% do,
that means we're always going to have friction.
In some cases it'll be like Lebanon.
By the way,
I've predicted that in Europe,
this is on record.
We can probably find that that in Europe within 15 2025 50 years,
we're going to have Lebanon all over the place and now it's starting to happen,
right?
At one point,
we were having daily attacks all over Europe.
So,
so again,
if you're going to increase Islamic immigration to the West,
of course most people are nice and just want to escape to a better work.
But are you willing to take the risks for what's about to happen?
Are you willing to accept people whose cultural and religious values are
perfectly antithetical to yours?
So example,
if you do pew surveys from around the Middle East or Islamic countries about
your views on Jews,
while you'll get things like 95 to 99% Jew hatred.
So if I am,
if I'm a Canadian Jew,
right,
and I see that 50,000 Syrians are going to come in,
is it that I'm filled with hatred towards Syrians or am I simply someone who
calculates the testicle irregularities and basically says that out of 50,000
people,
if 95% have endemic Jew hatred as part of their identity,
do I have a right to be concerned about this?
I,
I'm not worried about Haitians.
They're black people.
I'm not racist.
I'm not worried about the Vietnamese.
Right.
I'm worried about the cultural and religious baggage that you bring in.
What about your views towards cliteracy or homosexuality or a religious
minorities or,
or black dogs?
Darwin forbid,
if you're a black dog,
you're not,
I mean,
Muhammad hated dogs,
but he particularly hated black dogs.
Uh,
so again,
so what do they do at black dog?
Well,
go,
go on and you'll see some pretty ugly animal cruelty.
Uh,
they're not very tolerant towards dogs.
if you touch a dog before you're heading to prayer,
uh,
this is called an measures.
It's impure by the way.
The Kuffar,
the non Muslims are also nudges.
They're there.
They're there as in pure as urine and blood and sperm and feces.
So should I feel bad that there is an ideology that considers me and in pure
quality now does that mean that all Muslims are like that?
Of course not.
99% of the Muslims I've met have been lovely and many of them are my friends.
But we should be able to talk about what's inside those books.
And those books are not radical Islam.
They're Islam.
Well,
let me ask you this.
What's the alternative like save for Syrian refugees?
I mean any kind,
caring person who has for our fellow human
beings,
these people fleeing and sees the horrific conditions that they're,
that they're confronted with in their own country and they really don't have a
lot of options and they're trying to escape to the west.
What,
what are the options?
What do you do?
There are no clear answers.
I would certainly say you first placed the people who are most at risk and those
societies on in the front of the queue.
So you bring the Yazidi women,
you'll bring the Christians who are being persecuted women.
But what about the father?
If the dad is with the wife and the children,
you can't just have the father stay back behind the tent and you let the mom go
to Toronto with the kids.
No,
fair enough.
What I was saying though is that let people who are non-Islamic who are fleeing
those areas and the front of the queue first,
but isn't that,
isn't that religious persecution?
I mean,
or at the very least it's prejudice,
right?
I mean you're,
you're,
you're singling people out because of their ideology or because of what religion
they're from,
not because of their past behavior or any predictors whatsoever about their
future behavior.
But we do have some statistical irregularity about what types of values those
guys are going to come with.
So I'm not suggesting we closed the door.
Right.
So wouldn't that in a way,
I mean,
just to play devil's agitation,
wouldn't that in a way kind of put the Muslims in Toronto who do immigrant,
which would have picked that city who tried to immigrate to Canada in the same
sort of a position that your family was in in Lebanon,
where you were hiding the fact that you were Jews.
No one has an inalienable right to integrate anywhere.
Correct.
So if you wish to immigrate to the West,
then leave every single syllable that constitutes a belief,
attitude,
position,
value that is contrary to ours at the door and then welcome in my brother.
But man,
isn't that a crazy thing to say to someone who's entire life and their ideology
is a big part of their identity and who they are,
like how they view the world.
So that's the structure for which they interface with other human beings.
But if those values,
so let,
let's suppose I agree with you in a way I agree with you overall.
When I talk about the entire human population that it would be wonderful if we
did that.
But from individual to individual,
we know about the trials and tribulations that people go through on a day to day
life and religious freedom and religious ideology in many cases helps people get
through the pains of life.
It helps them get through the struggles.
I'm not saying that it's rational,
but I am saying that in many ways it's a scaffolding for their own personal
behavior.
Got It.
Uh,
you would have to then ensure that you'll religious practice is exclusively
practice privately.
Never should there ever be an intrusion into the public sphere.
No.
Asking for prayer rooms at the university.
They example that you gave is the slight creeping jihad,
right?
It's the slow.
It's uh,
so my next book is called tentatively might change death of the West by a
thousand cuts,
right?
That's the idea that when you take,
again,
a parable of the frog,
when you put it in boiling water and you do it very slowly,
the frog,
if you do it very,
very slowly,
if it falls below a just noticeable difference,
it doesn't notice that the temperature is rising until it's too late and it
boils to death.
Right?
So this idea of just noticeable difference is something that's very important in
this conversation.
We're not going to get Islamized overnight,
but Egypt,
before it became Islamic,
used to be non Islamic.
Once upon a time today it's about 10% Coptic Christians.
Turkey is now 99% Islamic.
One day it wasn't Iran.
The Great Persian empires were not Islamic.
Today,
it's almost exclusively Islamic.
So the United States and Canada are not going to become uh,
Islamic,
uh,
you know,
in the next 10 years.
But give it enough time,
have a long enough view of history and I worry about your grandchildren and
mine.
Uh,
and so we,
that's how you have an honest conversation.
And I'm not sure what the answer is.
One possibility,
which I've discussed with folks on my show who are trained lawyers,
is that there are provisions in the law,
at least in the United States,
to declare an ideology as being seditious,
right?
So in the same way that you could say that Nazi-ism is seditious to our values
or communism,
they are elements of Islam,
the nonspiritual parts that it doesn't take Einstein to recognize that they are
perfectly antithetical to every single value that you and I would hold dear as
Westerners.
So like what,
what would be some of those values?
So take for example shallow,
right?
Which is the Islamic law by which you organize society.
The first premise of Islamic law is that the,
uh,
crime,
its severity and its punishment depends on the identity of the perpetrator and
the victim.
So imagine the idea and the American constitution that justice is blind.
Well that is already violated as the most fundamental tenant of Sharia law.
If a Muslim kills a Jew,
it's very,
very different crime than if a Jew kills a Muslim.
You can just go,
go look up reliance of the traveller,
which is the English translation of Sharia law.
And you'll see all these things.
So why should we tolerate this kind of stuff?
Right?
Come in my Muslim brothers,
but keep the stuff that you,
yourself escaped from out of our country.
We don't want it.
And if you keep it out,
come in and let's grow together and hug it out.
But why should I be tolerant towards the intolerable?
I,
I agree with you in theory,
but I think the problem is as soon as you tell someone to not follow certain
aspects of their ideology,
those aspects become even more attractive.
And especially if they consider the west to be decadent and filled with sin and
fornicating and drinking and all the,
all the things they think of disgusting.
And then these people are the ones who are telling you that you can't follow the
word of God has brought down by the profit from up on high.
It becomes even more attractive to them.
So what do we do?
What?
So what's your trucks?
Psychedelic drugs.
Everyone gets on mushrooms.
And I'm kidding.
Not Kidding.
I really,
I really think you need transcendent experiences to escape from the day to day
vibration of normal life.
How about just the commitment to reason and science?
It would be wonderful if we could do that,
but people are so terrified of death and they're so terrified of the unknown.
And they're so terrified of not having structure.
People love having ideological structure that they can govern their life by.
Yeah.
Okay.